hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome to episode 61 of game
programming so last time we took a look
at creating the spawn level which is
right over here and implementing all the
tiles that are used and all the colors
for the tiles that users you can see
right here now this time today we're
gonna take a look at actually um you
know going into the spawn level I guess
so loading the spawn level into our game
so first of all this hierarchy we bought
here it seems little resources we've got
textures and then levels that's kind of
not cool because levels is in texture
let's just cut that and put it up yet so
we have interest in our reign this is
just a normal range rockery we have
resources and then we have levels of
textures awesome so now let's let's
frickin do it
so right now over here we've got a level
go spawn level right and it's in slash
levels / spawn right which is actually
correct because the thing last time I
fixed it but um it's in resources which
is already in the build path so you
don't even specify that but it is in in
in levels and then spawn dot PNG which
is where the file is located now what we
need to do now basically is is make sure
that we actually read all the tiles so
currently you can see that we've got
three different tiles and we return you
know a bunch of we're basically got
three different types of tiles returned
and obviously in our level there's a lot
more because if you look over here into
tile there are well there's freaking six
right here to the menu on you so far but
we need four so let's implement that
right now so if we go into tile we've
got out we've made all of our tiles but
he did that last time which is awesome
and over here we'll say that we actually
created all the spawn grass one has four
water war one will two and spawn floor
and we've already attribute a little
sprite so that's pretty easy we've
pretty much done everything so all we
need to do now is put it into practice
so over here instead of if tiles equals
you know at this color let's let's just
say that if tiles equals
tile dot color will be a set floor right
so if it's full then return tile dot
spawn for and if that equals style dot
color grass right then we'll return tile
dot spawn grass and so on until we till
get everything down so over here we'll
just say which one haven't we done head
for example hedge isn't really done yet
but also put it in here so that we can
um because because it does exist this
spawn edge and then we'll just copy the
swatch times what I need it
so toilet callicles wall one for example
then we'll return child born all one and
if and we going to Atlanta for wall too
as well I'm just trying to assume
through this all one even best picked he
can't really tell because I'm Ella kind
of like one and I think we've got that
no there's one more there's water which
we haven't actually done yet but um but
whatever I think how we even don't that
yeah we have we have made me fall for it
or be the object for Allah does that it
one two three five six that's it
okay so what we should be able to do now
is just launched our game and it should
it should yeah it should display but it
crashes and if we take a look at this
crash in depth we've actually getting
getting an illegal argument exception
now what does that mean you can say
right over here that's actually brought
up image IO to read what that means
basically is it is reading the wrong
like it can't find the file that's what
it means so I'm not exactly sure where
it's failing trade the file so Fritz run
here we can see that input equals
knowledge means the files are found in
load level so in spalling level over
here so I'm path with it what is path
come from looks like path comes from the
origin of path is right over here
because they over here that in our game
directory when we actually set a little
it was only it is equal to news porn
level textures levels leveled up and
Jake
now you can see straight away that all
I've done is I've moved levels the
folder up into you know a different
directory and what's happened as a
result of that the game's gotten broken
in two cases we fixed it in here all
right but um but it looks like it's kind
of the same fixed needs to be applied
yes that's that's bad programming that's
just lets me know that um that you know
if you've got to fix the same error
twice like you're not coding you're
doing it wrong bro like you know you're
not hurting properly so um if I go back
to level you'll say that level spawn
equals new and then we can set it equal
to news forum level actually drop it on
what that last time but it it comes to
news porn level bezel there's a part and
because it's static instead of this
right and if we go back to our game
novel instead of making a new instance
of it let's just set a vehicle to
leveled or spawn and that's it and that
kind of fixes that kind of kills three
birds with one stone first of all it
simplifies that card a lot and second of
all it solves that on that error that
input equals no error so yeah let's just
launch our game now and see what happens
all right would you look at that we are
in the level that we made that is pretty
cool that would catch a car looks like
the floor technical suck rubbish but um
but yeah look at that
that is awesome first time I've seen
that thing oh and there's a spawn point
I totally forgot about a spawn point
let's um let's say the spawn point for
next time because I want to talk okay -
how about how that's gonna work but um
yeah that's that's how we lowered our
umm it's how we load out well this is
really cool actually
apart from that the wall texture
actually looks pretty good
surprisingly but a flow tech show it
like it it kind of works but when I sort
of trails off here it kind of some
italics really beautiful as well
it's occlusion detection is obviously
something that will be implemented soon
I'm still not sure if I like the the 32
by 32 size player I'm not sure if I want
16 by 16 or 32 by 32
well obviously experiment both ways but
um yeah I'm still running it three and a
half thousand FPS which is awesome but
um yeah so
that's that's pretty damn awesome yeah
wow that's really cool
okay I'm actually yeah this is really
nice like aesthetically well yeah that's
sort of how our game rolls we can
provide some subtle shadows as well in
the future just to make it a little bit
better that's yeah they'll definitely be
implemented but um yeah so I'll see how
the sport level looks like which is um
which is pretty awesome so you can see
by the way that this is actually an
important note to note it's actually a
mere coincidence that could because if
you look at um I just go back into
levels right and spawn you can see that
I actually used a blue color firstborn
right into the spawn point was marked by
blue and it sort of blew a conservative
shade but that's more like teal in there
in the airfoil file but it's blue so why
is that happening
that is there because go into our code
and we look at this it says that if if
basically if none of these statements
are true in other words if the colors on
the level does not match up our colors
you know our tiles our tile colors out
to find Kyle colors and where it's going
to return a void time void tile is set
currently to be hotel right of water
it's that currently to be this color so
I mean we could probably make it black I
kind of like that color but um we could
just make a black puppeting zero that
and we raced out our game and go all the
way down oh yeah this is right away
there's black but um let's just go down
the reason that I don't like to make it
black this feels like a path the reason
about that I don't want to want to make
it black is because um black can
sometimes like especially when you're
doing lighting black just black so don't
interfere with that but um yeah so me I
just meant black so I'll probably keep
it as absolute cold that'll be like our
signature boy tile color but other than
that you know it's in your instantly
like alright there's a void tile there
something's not working or something
isn't nothing working and it's supposed
to which is out which is pretty sick but
yeah anyway that's episode 61 I'm game
programming now I'm sorry to sadden you
guys with this news but I'm actually
going away for a week which means I will
not be home
in my office for a week which means I
can't make videos for a week so um yeah
I'm sorry about that but game
programming will resume on the 9th of
February I believe yeah yes because I'm
leaving tomorrow I'll be back on the 8th
and obvious I'll be too tired then to
make a video but um so it's Saturday I
think it's Saturday let me just check
quickly yep Saturday the 9th of February
that's when the next episode again
program will be but until then guys have
a great week a great next week and I'll
see you guys later
you